[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه هو من
جميع الجوانب
مع انطلاقى صافره البدايه المغرب على بعد
خطوتين من لقب التتويجي بكاس العالم
[تصفيق]
يا ورده
المغرب
وفرنسا تتاهب بالنجوم
باريس تتاهب امنيا قبل مباراه منتخبها مع
المغرب وتنشروا اكثر من 10,000 شرطي
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
ايران تلوح بمضيق هرمز مقابل لاحتجاجاته
وتعزوها الى الدعم الخارجيه للمتظاهرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم سيبقى اسم المغرب مسطرا باحرف من
ذهب في سجلات اغلى البطولات كاس العالم
قبل لحظات انطلقت مباراه المنتخب المغربي
ونظيره الفرنسي في نصف نهائي مونديال قطر
يتقابل فيها الصديقان اشرف حكيمي
والفرنسيه كيليان مبابي مقابله الخصمان
منتخب اسود الاطلس اخترق السقف الوهمي
الذي لم تتمكن المنتخبات العربيه ولا
الافريقيه من اختراقي الدوره الثمانيه
ثلاث محاولات افريقيه سابقه باءت بالفشل
الكاميرون عام 1990 والسنغال عام 2002
وغانا عام 2010 كان خط النهايه دور ربع
النهائي
المنتخب المغربي تجاوز هذا الخط للمغرب
اولا وللمنتخبات الافريقيه وللعربي ثانيا
ليست هذه الاطراف وحدها من يدعمها المنتخب
المغربي اذ نشهد او تشهد دول عده دول
عالميه مؤازره كبيره من مختلف القارات
للمغرب الحصان الاسود في هذه البطوله
انطلقت المباراه منذ لحظات كما ذكرنا
وسنعرف نتيجتها الليله لكن ايا كانت
النتيجه يبقى الانجاز المغربي كبيرا وتخطى
حدود المملكه المغربيه ودول العربيه
والقاره الافريقيه ليكتب اسم المغرب كاحد
افضل اربعه منتخبات في العالم
[تصفيق]
حبيبي حبيبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وينضم الينا شبكه مراسلينا من الدوحه مفوض
العربيه ليث بزاري من باريس حسين قنيبر من
القاهره احمد عثمان ومن عمان سهى جميل
اهلا بكم جميعا ابدا معك
ليث انطلقت المباراه
والحماس باقصى درجاته ما توقعات يعني
الناس الذين تتحدث معهم ماذا يتوقعون ان
تكون النتيجه
مبروك علينا هذه البدايه وما زال مازال
مازال تدفق المشجعين المغاربه والعرب ليس
فقط المشجعين راويه والمشجعات اللواتي
وصلنا من الرباط من مدن مغربيه اخرى
لتشجيع المنتخب المغربي هذه السيده وصلت
قبل شهر من اليوم لمتابعه المونديال
وتشجيع المنتخب المغربي شو فيك تحكي لنا
عن المباراه التي تحدث الان خلفنا في ملعب
البيت هنا في الدوحه
الحمد لله ربي نصرنا في بلد العرب نصرنا
كعرف بلاد العرب همم هذا الشيء كثير حلو
بالنسبه لنا رفعوا راسنا يعني الحد الكبير
ونتمنى ان شاء الله خير ان شاء الله مرورك
اويل سير سير ههه ولكن انت تابعت
المباريات دخلت قبل هالمره
تبعتي مباريات مباراه اتوقع المغرب
البرتغال
مباراه وكانت كنجد مصدومه يعني ما كنا
نتوقع لها الدرجه يعني نكون في هذا
المستوى والله ما كنا نتوقع ابدا بس الحمد
لله نصرنا الرب وان شاء الله يكون خير وان
شاء الله هنفوز على فرنسا وهمم وان شاء
الله كاس العالم
هل هناك هتافات خاصه بالنساء للمنتخب
المغرب
زغروته مباشره على الهواء راويه من
الصبايا المغربيات الموجودين هون شكرا
لكما طبعا اذا اخذنا الكاميرا مع جوليا سي
ام بيفوار هناك اشخاص اخرون يرتدون اشياء
مختلفه هنا الشخص انت اه ههه هو في من
خلال يقوم بمباشر مع تلفزيون الاخر هذا ما
يحصل في المباشر احيانا
ولكن
تتواجد وسطهم ابقى معنا ننتقل الى حسين
قنيبر حسين يعني قبل ان نتحدث عن
الاجراءات الامنيه اود ان تنقل لصوره
الحماس الفرنسي والحماس همم حماس الجاليات
العربيه همم
الان همم ادخل المنتخب الفرنسي الهدف
الاول بشباك المنتخب المغربي تفضل
مساء الخير يا راويه انت وانا نشتريكان
هذه الليله في الخيبه في خيبتنا لناحيه
عدم تمكننا من حضور هذه المباراه الخلافه
لزميلاتنا ميسون التي ودعتك قبل دقائق
متباهيه بانها ذاهبه الى هناك في الواقع
يعني نبدا بالصوره التي ينقلها زميل
المصور زكري صبحي عفوا تشاهدين القوى
الامنيه الفرنسيه منتشره بكثافه هنا طبعا
تردد قبل دقيقتين اصداء الهدف الذي حققه
المنتخب الفرنسي همم في مواجهه المنتخب
المغربي همم هذه الاجراءات الامنيه عبر
فرنسا سينتشر 10,000 بل انتشر 10,000 شرطي
لمواجهه بل لمواكبه الاحتفالات التي ستعقب
انتهاء المباراه بين فرنسا والمغرب من بين
هؤلاء خمسه الاف ينتشيرون في العاصمه
ومحيطها من ضمنهم الفان و200 ينتشرون
شهادت الشانزليزيه والجدات 10 المجاوره
لها لو اعطينا الكلمه اللي همم لجمهور
المنتخبين هنا قبل دقائق التقيت برمي
ويزيد يحملان العالم الفرنسي ولكن يزيد
مغربي المولود في فرنسا هو فرنسي من اصل
مغربي يرتدي ثيابا تشير الى تضامنه مع
المنتخب المغربي لكنه يحمل ايضا العالم
الفرنسي همم زميله صديقه رميه من مؤيدين
المنتخب الفرنسي طبعا اسالهما
سريعاراغميستيك ما هي توقعاتك هذه الليله
همم
[موسيقى]
كنت اتوقع هدفا لفرنسا وهدف للمغرب الان
اتوقع التعادل بين فرنسا والمغرب ثم
التمديد ثم فوز لفرنسا
مرمي يزيد كونتا اوفو ذاتنائهم
اقول له انت مغربي في فرنسا من اصل مغربي
ولكنك تحمل العالم الفرنسي اشرح لنا ذلك
وام مغربيهين
لو فازت المغرب بكاس العالم او فرنسا فانا
ساكون سعيدا يقول يزيد ميرسي يزيد
هنا مع اشاره الى مخاوف من احتمال حصول
اضطرابات لاحقا عن هذه المخاوف سنتحدث
خلال هذه الساعه في هذه التغطيه للمباراه
تحسين ساعود اليك بعد قليل ننتقل الى احمد
عثمان من القاهره احمد كيف تتابع الجماهير
المصريه هذه المباراه يعني شاهدنا الكثير
من الفيديوهات والدعم المصري همم للجمهور
المغربي
وللمنتخب هيك يا ريت همم الكاميرا ترينا
اين تتواجد والجماهير الداعمه
همم نعم اهلا بكم انا اتواجد الان في احد
يعني المقاهي المعروفه او التي اشتهرت في
الفتره الاخيره بانها تمثل تواجد لي
الجاليه المغربيه في مصر هي ليست جاريه
كبيره بطبيعه الحال ولكن هذا المكان يعني
اشتهر في الفتره الاخيره حيث ان هناك تدفق
كبير جدا من مشجعين منتخب المغرب وايضا من
المشجعين من من المصريين الذين ياتون الى
هذا المكان لمؤازره الفريق الجزائري
بالفعل هذه
المباريات التي نجح المنتخب المغربي موصوف
فيها الى دوري الاربعه كانت محطه اهتمام
كبير جدا من الجمهور المصريه الذي يتفاعل
مع كل مباراه للفريق المغربي ونجاحه في
العبور من دور الى دور يعني حتى الان
استطيع ان نقول بانها ما يحدث في المقاهي
المصريه من وجود جماهيري كبير جدا على
جميع المستويات وكانه مشهد قريب لمتابعه
كانها مشاهده في المنتخب المصري هناك
رهانك على المنتخب المغربي ربما منذ بدايه
البطوله كان هناك احد من الحزن لدى الشارع
المصري مشاركه الفريق المصري ولكن الاداء
الجيد والطيب نعم نعم سنعود اليك بعد قليل
وانتقل الى مراسلتنا سهى جميل من عمان سهى
يعني كيف يتفاعل الجمهور الاردني مع هذه
المباراه التي لاول مره يصل فريق عربي الى
هذا المستوى وهذه المرحله المت دماء
[تصفيق]
تاكيد هي مواجهه تاريخيه خاصه وان المغرب
هو اول فريق عربي بتاريخ المونديال يصل
الى نصف النهائيات ما يزال سقف التوقعات
بالنسبه للاردنيين واتوقع للجميع عالي جدا
بطاقته
بالمنتخب المغربي خاصه وانه يعني تفوق على
فريق قوي وهو البرتغال والان هو يواجه
الفريق الفرنسي او المنتخب الفرنسي ورغم
انه منذ قليل سدد ال همم المنتخب الفرنسي
همم جول في مرمى منتخب المغرب لكن ما تزال
همم الامنيات وسقط التوقعات والامال ما
زال تراوح مكانا عاليا جدا
بالفريق والمنتخب المغربي التحضيرات في
جميع همم الخيام المخصصه لحضور هذه
المباراه الى المقاهي امتلات الاردنيين
كانت حركه الشوارع قبل قليل شبه خالي بسبب
يعني توجهها الاردني الى الاماكن المخصصه
لحضور هذه المباراه التاريخيه طبعا عربيه
الشعور عربي
الشعب الاردني الجمهور الاردني لا يختلف
عن اي يعني امنيات او احلام شعب عربي اخر
بامنياتي بفوز المنتخب المغربي همم
ينتظرون
النتائج في هذه المباراه يتمنون ان يصل
المنتخب المغربي غدا لمواجهه ايضا الفريق
تفوز يوم امس على كرواتيا وهو الارجنتين
نحن نتمنى ونحن ننتظر النتائج رغم تسديد
المنتخب الفرنسي هذا الجول هذا لا يعني
ابدا طبعا
صوتنا همم
ابقي معنا وكذلك باقي مراسلين مذكر بانه
الهدف الاول اتى بالدقيقه الخامسه من تيو
همم
هو لاعب المنتخب الفرنسي كما ذكرنا اذا
منتخب المغربي يسعى للكتابه صفحه جديده في
كتب التاريخ الكروي تاريخ كره القدم
العربيه والافريقيه ومحاوله الوصول الى
نهائي بطوله كاس العالم مدرب المنتخب وليد
الرجراجي تسال لما لا نصل الى نهائي كاس
العالم واكد ان فريقه سيبدي رغبه كبيره
كما سيحاول تحقيقه مفاجاه اكد الرجراجي ان
منتخبه جاء الى هذه البطوله لتغيير
العقليات داخل القاره الافريقيه والهام
الاجيال القادمه من اللاعبين والمنتخبات
بان التفاني والاصرار يجعل ما يتصوره
البعض مستحيلا على الورق امرا واقعيه على
الميدان الاخضر لائحه الانتصارات المغربيه
في هذه البطوله ضمت اسماء بلجيكا وكندا في
دور المجموعات واسبانيا في الدور الثاني
واخيرا البرتغال في ربع النهائي المباراه
التاريخيه تدور الان اسود اطلس امام
الديوك الفرنسيه المغرب يتميز بخطوط
متجانسه في حراسه المرمى والدفاع وخط
الوسط والهجوم حتى الان تلقى المنتخب
المغربي هدفا واحدا بنران صديقه هدفان اذا
منذ لحظات اسود الاطلس وعلى لسان مدربهم
قال ان الوصول لنصف النهائي ليس الهدف
الاكبر وان المنتخب يريد الذهاب الى ابعد
من ذلك اضاف الرجراجي ان المغرب ربما لا
يكون مرشحا للفوز لكن لاعبيه على ثقه
بقدوراتها
سنخرج من كل مباراه
مع قيمنا منها لذلك كما قلت في بدايه
المسابقه نحن بالفوز بكاس العالم وكل ما
تقدمنا اكثر اقتربنا من حلمنا لذلك غدا
سنكافح للمضي قدما نحن واثقون حتى لو صارت
كل التوقعات ضدنا ربما كونوا مجانين ولكن
من الجيد ان تكون مجنونا
ص مقدمه الاخبار الرياضيه في قناه العربيه
اهلا بك محمد يعني الفريق المغربي تلقى
بالدقيقه الخامسه يعني مع بدايه المباراه
لهدف من المنتخب الفرنسي هل برايك يمكن ان
يعوض النتيجه وان يلعب بشكل افضل ل- اا
يعني يسجل هدف اخر
مباراه صعبه جدا في البدايه عن المنتخب
المغربي ما فيها ايه نقاش مباراه يعني
امام واحد افضل المنتخبات في البطوله من
حيث الهجوم لكن الامكانيات الكبيره اللي
عند المنتخب المغربي ان شاء الله تساعده
في انه يمتص هذه امكاني
قوه المنتخب المغربي
ممتاز في الجوانب الدفاعيه يتلقى هدف في
الدقائق الخمس الاولى لا يعني انه فقد هذه
الميزه وبالتالي يمكن المرهنه على امكانيه
عوده المنتخب المغربي في الاجواء المباراه
امتصاص الضغط الذي ممكن يشكل عليه المنتخب
الفرنسي وبالتالي بامكان انه يعود في اي
لحظه الى الى اجواء المباراه يعني نشات
حتى في الاحصائيات مباشره اللي تجينا الان
من المباراه انه حتى في نسب الاستحواذ
المنتخب المغربي همم نسبه الاستحواذ عنده
اعلى هي 58% قد تكون اعلى نسبه استحواذ
اصلا للمنتخب المغربي طول البطوله حتى
الان في خلال الدقائق ال 19 اللي راحت من
الشوط الاول وبالتالي بامكان المنتخب
المغربي اللي تعودنا عليه انه يلعب
من الطرق همم يعني فيها ارتداد سريع على
على الخصم انه يعود الى اجواء المباراه
وان ممكن يسجل ان شاء الله هدف التعادل
وحتى ان شاء الله باذن الله عز وجل هدف
همم الفوز والانتصاب
فرنسا يوم امس ضد اياد الشام صرح بانه
اللاعبين فريقو يتجهزون لمواجهه المغرب
وخاصه الضجيج الجماهيري وبانه يحسب حساب
لهذه الجماهير الكبيره العربيه المغربيه
المتواجده لدعم المنتخب المغربي عنصر
الجمهور عنصر انه هذه المباراه تلعب على
ارض عربيه
وبين اهلك مثل ما يقال بالعاميه ما
اهميتها جدا انك تلعب مباراه امام جمهورك
يعني يعني على الاقل في لو لم يكن معك
جمهورك انت تحرم الخصم من ميزه انه يكون
عنده جمهور يحفظه ويساعده وفي اي لحظه
ممكن انه جمهورك ايضا يساعدك ويحفزك ويعيد
ويعيدك الى اجواء المباراه يعني بالتاكيد
انه النتائجات المنتخبات العربيه طبعا
احنا لا يعني بعيدا عن التاهل المغرب الى
نصف النهائي لكن حتى منذ انتهاء الدور
الاول الجميع يتحدث عن ان المنتخبات
العربيه قدمت افضل نتائج لها في هذه
النسخه وذلك يعود بشكل كبير جدا الى
الحضور الجماهير الكبير معها الى الدعم
الجماهير الكبير اللي لاقته من المشجعيها
ومن انصارها راويه ما ننسى الجزئيه ثانيه
برده مهمه جدا انه المنتخبات العربيه
المنتخبات عاطفيه كثير يعني يحفزها كثير
انه تكون ال- ال- الاصوات اللي في الملعب
مالوفه لها وايضا يعني يربطها انه عمان
نستطيع ان نقول اذا كانت الاصوات الموجوده
في الملعب مختلفه عن لهجتها او حتى عنها
تعتاد عليها بالتالي انه نشاهد هذا الفرق
اللي بين اللاعبين العرب وغير العرب انه
اللاعبين غير العرب يعني ممكن همم معتدين
على انهم يلعبوا في اصواتهم ما يفهموها
وما يعرفوها
على عكس اللاعبين العرب اللي يهتموا كثير
بهذه الجزئيه وتعني لهم الشيطان
يعني حدث
نا خلقها المنتخب المغربي بما يخص مشاركات
المنتخبات العربيه
بالسنوات القادمه
بالمونديال ما الذي غيروا المنتخب المغربي
همم بالنسبه للكره المغربيه انجاز كبير
جدا بالنسبه
للجماهير المغربيه امر يفتخرون فيه لكن
ايضا بالنسبه للجماهير العربيه امر
افتخرون فيه ويضع ايضا الكره في ملعب
المسيرين الرياضيين في كل الدول العربيه
انه في فرصه ان نحقق انجازات مثل انجاز
المغرب ليش ما نسوي زي كده بالتالي حتى
الضغوط اللي موجوده عند اللاعبين العرب
عقده النقص اللي تكون احيانا موجوده عند
بعض المنتخبات وبعض اللاعبين قد تكون
تنتهي بهذه المشاركه التاريخيه الكبيره
بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي راويه يعني خلينا
نتذكر انه النسخه المقبله 2026 راح تكون
بمشاركه 48 منتخب بدلا من همم بس سته 32
منتخب في النسخه الحاليه وبالتالي في فرصه
كبيره جدا نشوف منتخبات عربيه اكثر في
النسخه المقبله ممكن نشوف سته سبعه ثمانيه
منتخبات عربيه تشارك في النسخه المقبله
وبالتالي ننتظر نتيجه افضل واداء افضل وان
شاء الله باذن الله عز وجل يكون في اثنين
او على الاقل ثلاث منتخبات في ربع النهائي
المقبل ما نتكلم على نصف النهائي نتكلم
على الربع النهائي كانستهدف منطقي
بالامكان الوصول اليه
في قناه العربيه في هذه الساعه الاخباريه
تاهوبا للقاء فرنسا والمغرب رفعت الشرطه
الفرنسيه درجه الاستعداد قبل المباراه
التي يخوضها المنتخبان حاليا وزيره
الداخليه
جيرالد دارمانا قالت ان او قال في ان
بلاده ستحشد نحو عشره الاف من افراد
الشرطه في جميع انحاء البلاد نصفهم في
المنطقه المحيطه بباريس و200 ااه من
الشرطه داخل العاصمه وهو ضعف عدد افراد
الامن الذين حشدتهم السلطات الفرنسيه خلال
المباريات السابقه لفرنسا الوزير اكد ان
المغاربه مثل الفرنسيين من حقهم الاحتفال
لكن في ظل ظروف امنيه جيده وقال ايضا ان
السلطات لن تغلق شارع الشانزليزيه
بالعاصمه بريسه والذي يستقطب الراغبين في
الاحتفال بالمناسبات الرياضيه والمظاهرات
ايضا السلطات الفرنسيه قررت ايضا اقامت
نحو 500 نقطه امنيه في باريس ومناطق اخرى
لتفتيش المشجعين بحثا عن العاب ناريه او
قنابل دخ
وينضم الينا من الدوحه مفرد العربيه نايف
الثقيل اهلا بك نايف اين تتواجد يعني يبدو
انك في احدى نقاط
الفانزون او نقاط تجمع يعني المشجعين انقل
لنا الاجواء
من قبل بدايه المونديال ونحن في الدوحه
ولكن اليوم الوضع مختلف جدا نحن ليس في
منطقه
اماكن الدوحه تحولت كلها مناطق للجماهير
لدعم اللي همم المنتخب المغربي هذه
المنطقه همم اذا كانت المدرجات بيع
التذاكر بالكامل في جميع المناطق التي
احداها التي تشاهدينها خلفي تم حجزها
بالكامل قبل ثلاثه ايام لا يوجد هناك اي
مكان واي متسع همم
لاي تواجد الجماهير امام الشهادات هناك
امتلاء للساحات العامه نعلم انه في عدد
كبير من الطائرات حضرت من من المغرب وايضا
هناك طائرات حضرت من من الدول الخليج التي
يسمح لها بالدخول بدون بطاقه هيئه شاهدت
اليوم جنسيات مختلفه همم جنسياته اردنيه
وجميع الجنسيات العربيه متواجد اليوم
للمغرب هناك جماهير ذهبت الى المدرجات
وهناك جماهير تدعم المنتخب همم المغربي في
الساحات كما تشاهدين خلفي بالكاد هذه
منطقه من من يعني عشوات المناطق في الدوحه
ممتلئه بالكامل وهي يتابعون مباراه همم
المغرب وبالتاكيد يعني ستكون هناك
احتفالات في شوارع الدوحه في حال همم تاهل
المنتخب المغربي الى همم
كل يوم شاهدت جماهير مغربيه تبكي همم حسره
على عدم قدرتها على همم الحضور في مدرجات
الملعب همم قيمه التذاكر وصلت الى اسعار
همم جنونيه همم اقبال كبير على التذاكر
ايضا هناك همم سوق همم سوداء ولو كانت
قليله همم نوعا همم ولكن قد الحدث احيانا
اذا الطلب عالي جدا على يكون هناك همم
بالطبيعي ان يكون هناك سوق سوداء همم
للتذاكر راويه ابقى معي نايف الثقيل
وننتقل الى حسين قنيبر من باريس حسين يعني
الشرطه الفرنسيه رفعت درجه الاستعداد همم
ولكنها لم تغلق شارع الشانزليزيه حدثنا عن
الاجراءات الامنيه بهذه الليله
نعم في الواقع اترك الصوره تتحدث عن هذه
الاجراءات الامنيه اعداد كبيره من العناصر
عناصر الشرطه تنتشر عند جده وفي محيطها
على مستوى فرنسا كلها هناك 10 الاف
كيبون الاحتفالات التي ستعقب انتهاء
المباراه بين فرنسا والمغرب هذه الليله من
بين هؤلاء العشره الاف هناك خمسه الاف
ينتشرون في العاصمه باريس وضواحيها ومن
ضمنهم الفان 21 ينتشرون عند جده
والجدات المجاوره لها الشرطه هنا منتشره
في كل مكان كما تشاهدون وايضا حتى على
جانبي الرصيف عند الجده في اماكن لم نكن
نتوقع ان الشرطه تتواجد فيها هنا مثلا
من الناحيه الاخرى كما تشاهدين سيارات
شرطه
شاحنات منتشره في كل مكان
وعدد الناس هنا قلبك كثير مما هو عليه
عاده في هذه الساعه من الليل تكون الاعداد
اكبر بكثير ولكن معظم الناس يشاهدون
الليله المباراه الا قليله من الناس جاءت
الى هنا من ضمنهم معي سعيده ونزيهه
المغربيه
اللتان ستتحدثان الينا نزيهه مساء الخير
مساء الخير
توقعاتك بالنسبه لهذه الليله طبعا انا من
اصول مغربيه ونتمنى ان شاء الله المغرب
يكون هو الفائز رغم الصعوبات والفريق
القوي بتاع فرنسا ونتمنى ان شاء الله
الدعاء همم
الفريق المغربي باش ان شاء الله ياخذ كاس
العالم ان شاء الله هذه السنه
فرنسيه من اصول مغربيه عندك الجنسيه
الفرنسيه الفرنسيه طب يعني هذا لا يدفعك
التضامن ولو قليلا ايضا مع المنتخب
الفرنسي منتخب البلد الذي استقبلك وانت
تعيشين هنا منذ مده طويله همم قليل شويه
قليل همم لان طبعي كبرت في المغرب في
المغرب
وطبعي مغربي واصولي مغربيه نحب باغيه ان
شاء الله المغرب يربح ولكن فرنسا الى ربحه
همم ما غاديش نكون محضر خير يا حسين ان
شاء الله يكون خير الفريق المغربي شكرا
شكرا نزيهه سعيده كلمه عن توقعاتك الليله
همم
شكرا لك سعيده التي لاسمك سعيده اتمنى ان
اتمنى ان تكوني اسعد بعد انتهاء المباراه
وننزيلها شكرا لك نعتمد على النزاهه الحكم
عند اعلان النتائج انا دائما محضر بخير يا
راويه لكنني احاول ان اكون وسطيا همم لانه
يعني بين المغرب وفرنسا قلبه الكثيرين
قلوب الكثيرين موزعه بين فرنسا من جهه
والمغرب من جهه اخرى راويه شكرا جزيلا لك
حسين سنعود اليك بخلال هذه النشره وايضا
من الدوحه نايف الثقيل مفضل العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لكم
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل هل تصدق
صدفه الارقام مع المغرب من اخوان متى الى
حكيم زياش صدفه الارقام في كلمه السر
والقبعه الخاصه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مراجعه اسود الاطلس مع
الديوك في نصف نهائي كاس العالم كبيرا في
الصحافه الفرنسيه
تطرقت الصحافه الفرنسيه للجوانب المرتبطه
بالمباراه من اداء المنتخبين في البطوله
والماضي المشترك والروابط الثقافيه بين
الرباط وباريس هذه المباراه ستكون الاولى
بين المنتخبين في تاريخ بطولات كاس العالم
وما عداها كان فقط مباريات وديه صحيفه
الاموم قالت ان اسود الاطلس اخترقوا السقف
الزجاجي للدول الافريقيه وهو دور الثمانيه
او ربع النهائي الذي لم تستطع سابقا الفرق
الافريقيه تجاوزها في نفس السياق قالت
صحيفه لاكوا ان المواجهه تحمل امال القاره
الافريقيه والعالم العربي مضيفه ان وجود
جاليه مغربيه كبيره في فرنسا قد يشكل نوعا
من الحساسيه بين الجماهير اما صحيفه
باريزيا فقد نوهت الى ان فرنسا ستواجه
يكتب تاريخه بعد سنوات من الخيبات واشارت
الى ان الفوز على البرتغال في الدوري
الماضي لخص روح بلد باكمله
صحيفه الرياضيه عن هناك عددها الصادر
اليوم الاربعاء بعبارات ثلاثه نجوم امام
الاعين في اشاره الى رغبه فرنسا بالفوز
بلقب عالمي ثالث سيكون الثاني تواليا
انتحقق اضافت الصحيفه ان مهمه فرنسا لن
تكون سهله خاصه وان المنتخب المغربي صارم
في كل لحظات المباراه ولا يترك فرصه للخصم
لاختراق دفاعاته من جانبها قالت لوجونال
دو ديمونش الى المنتخب المغربي فريق لا
يستهان به وقادر على استغلال انصاف الفراس
انه شعور خاصه
مغاربه مؤيدين لفريقهم وهذا شيء رائع
بالنسبه لهم لانها المره الاولى التي يصل
فيها فريق افريقي الى هذا الحد القريب جدا
من النهائي
من اجلهم ونمل ان تسيير الامور بثلاثه لكن
هذا لطيف للغايه لانها مع الجاليه
المغربيه هنا انها لعبه بين الاخوه الليله
سيكون خصوما في الملعب ولكن هذا سيتبعه
حفل كبير بالفوز
وينضم الينا من جديد
ليث بزاري مو فاضي العربيه من الدوحه من
امام ستاد البيت او ملعب البيت هذا الملعب
الذي يعني كان فيها
الاحتفال الاول وانطلاق بطوله كاس العالم
ليث يعني كانك ابتعدت قليلا عن الجماهير
خلي الجماهير تتحدث اليوم
بعم راويه الجماهير الاسد الكثير منهم
دخلوا الى هذا الملعب الى استاد البيت
68,472 مشجع دخل الى هذا ستاد وهذا الخط
المستقيم للذين وصلوا للتو على عجاله
والذين تاخروا للوصول الى الى هذا الملعب
لمشاهده المباراه بين المنتخب المغربي
والمنتخب الفرنسي الكثير داخل يدخل الان
نشاهد هؤلاء يعني هؤلاء الاشخاص في عمق
الصوره الذين يدخلون الان عندنا صوره
المياه الحمراء في عمق الصوره هناك وهناك
اشخاص اخرون هناك سيدتان امام الكاميرا
يحاولان يحاولنا الدخول الى الملعب
لمتابعه المباراه
همم فيما يخص ذاكر الدخول الى المباراه
هذه المباراه المهمه يعني همم احيانا في
اشخاص لم يحصلوا عليها بعبر اون لاين او
من خلال موقع الفيفا كان هناك
التذاكر حول الملعب
يعني المغرب امن التذاكر لي الناس يعني من
خلال حديثك معهم
نعم الشقين راويه الكثير من المشجعين
المغاربه اتوا بتذاكر طائره وتذاكر ملعب
تذاكر لمشاهده المباراه وكذلك شاهدنا
اشخاص يحاولون شراء بعض التذاكر اي يعني
بعض الاشخاص الذين لا يفضلون الدخول او
مشاهده المباراه واشتروا هذه التذاكر
مسبقا يعني قبل عندما تم فتح باب شراء
التذاكر ويحاولون وياتون الى هذه المنطقه
حول الملاعب ليس فقط ملعب او استاد البيت
الثمامه والخليفه ون 7 4 والملاعب الاخرى
والسيل كذلك يقومون بشراءه كانت تذاكر
وشاهدت اذكر تماما عندما كانت هناك مباراه
للمنتخب البرازيلي شخص مصري قام بدخول
بالدخول الى الملعب قبل خمس دقائق من
انتهاء المباراه كان حلمه ان يشاهد
المنتخب البرازيلي يلعب في احد الملاعب
ضمن المونديال طبعا وان يشاهد ذلك ولو لضع
دقائق وهذا ما يحصل يعني الكثير من ال- من
الاشخاص الذين ياتون تفضلوا نسالكم سؤال
هون في همم همم اهلا وسهلا من وين انتم
طب ليه ما فتوا على الملعب شو شو يعني ما
معكم تذاكر صاحبنا
صاحبكم بتكون خلصت المباراه
الكوري النتيجه هلا الهدف الاول لا يعني
شيئا طبعا هناك اهداف اخرى طبعا ااه ان
شاء الله المغرب منتخب قوي ان شاء الله
يرجع في النتيجه
ويكسب ان شاء الله كلنا مع المغرب
الى مصر فتطواني فلا احد يفرقنا ولا دين
يفرقنا لسان الضاد يجمعنا بغسان وعدنان
الامه العربيه تعيش الامه العربيه تعيش
الامه العربيه
العرب كلهم اليوم
اتحاد العرب مع بعضهم البعض كل العرب
اليوم يتمنون فوز المنتخب المغربي ننتقل
الى الدار البيضاء مع مراسلنا الخليل ولد
جدود اهلا بك خليل يعني تفضل انقل لنا
الصوره من عندك وانت من وراءك يعني
المشاهد مشجعين للمنتخب المغربي
في قاعه وسط الدار البيضاء سبع فيها جمهور
من كازابلانكا هذه المباريات هذه الدقائق
صعبه
الجمهور هنا والمغاربه يحبسون انفاسهم وكل
العرب في انتظاره هدف في التعادل الامال
تبقى عريضه في ان يتمكن المنتخب المغربي
الذي يظهر همم جهدا كبيرا ومستمر في
الاداء بشكل جيد كما يلاحظ الجمهور في ان
يتمكن من تحقيق
ايضا قبل همم تبدا المباريات الاجواء كانت
حماسيه وكانت هناك احتفالات والجميع ينتظر
الليله همم فوز المنتخب المغربي وهذه
الليله ستكون ليله استثنائيه هناك
استعدادات الاحتفالات اكبر وافهم في
كازابلان وفي كل مدن المغرب اذا ما تمكن
المنتخب المغربي من التجاوز الى الدوري
النهائي
وبالتالي يكون اول منتخب عربي وافريقي يصل
الى نهائي كاس العالم الجمهور هنا يتفاعل
مع الجهد الذي يبذله الدفاع المنتخب
المغربي في صد الهجمات الفرنسيه ومع كل
هجمه مرتده وكل محاوله من المنتخب المغربي
لتسجيل هدف هذه هي الاجواء الان مع امل
كبير وتركب في انتظار هدف التعادل
ان شاء الله كما يامل الجمال شكرا جزيلا
لك الخليل مراسل العربيه من الدار البيضاء
ظاهره غريبه مشاهدينا ربطتها مواقع رياضيه
بين بطل كاس العالم ونادي تشيلسي
الانجليزي قد توحي بتتويج المغرب كيف
دعونا نرى الارتباط الغريب يشير الى انه
منذ عام 2010 ينجح احد لاعبي تشيلسي في
الفوز بكاس العالم عندما يرتدي اخر رقمين
من العام نفسه نبدا مع اخوان ماتا وعام
2010 حينها كان الاسبان اخوان ماتا يرتدي
الرقم 10 في تشيلسي وفاز مع منتخب بلاده
بمونديال جنوب افريقيا في البطوله التاليه
التي نظمتها البرازيل كان الالماني
صاحب الرقم 14 مع تشيلسي وظفر بكاس العالم
الى كاس العالم في روسيا الان كانت في عام
2018 وتكررت المصادفه حينها حقق اوليفيا
جيرو البطوله وكان يرتدي الرقم 18 بنا
تشيلسي نحن الان في عام 2022 الانظار تتجه
الى صاحب الرقم 22 في تشيلسي فمن هو هو
المغربي حكيم زياش قيل قديمه
كذب المنجمون ولو صدق ربما تكون صدفه بحث
لكن يبقى ان الاهم هو المجهود الذي يقدمه
على ارض الملعب بغض النظر عن الرقم الذي
يحمله
عن هذه المصادفات وغيرها من التحليلات
الرياضيه ينضم الينا من جديد ازمير محمد
القناص مقدمه الاخبار الرياضيه في قناه
العربيه اهلا بك همم محمد يعني المغربي
حكيم زياش يلعب في تشيلسي همم يلعب على
دكه الاحتياط بعد هذا المونديال وبعد
الانجازات التي حققها مع المنتخب المغربي
همم كيف ستتغير نظره نادي تشيلسي له وضعه
كيف سيتغير هل سيكون لاعبا اساسيا
نتكلم شويه عن نجوم المنتخب المغربي اللي
قدموا اداء مبهر في هذه البطوله ولا يتم
التعامل معاهم
بتقدير لمواهبهم وتقدير كبير جدا
لامكانياتهم في في البلدان
الاوروبيه تحديدا في الانديه اللي يلعبون
فيها يعني لو تحدثنا عن حكيم زياش ايضا
واحد من ابرز اللاعبين في البطوله ااه لم
يشارك بدرجه كبيره جدا مع تشيلسي هذا
الموسم فقط في بضعه مباريات وحتى يعني
يدخل احتياطي كثير من الاحيان او في كل
الاحيان تقريبا وكانت الاخبار تربطه
بالانتقال حتى صيفا من همم تشيلسي قبل ان
يقرر النادي القاء عليه حتى كانت هناك
اخبار انه ممكن همم
كان هناك هدف وشكل المنتخب المغربي ولكن
لم يسجل
المنتخب الفرنسي او لا والله لوريس ابعد
الكره ببراءه لكن نتحدث
راويه عن امكانيه انه كان هناك حديث عن
رحيل زياش وعودته حتى الى هولندا يعني
استبداوا كما يقال في مسيره الكرويه لكن
اتوقع بعد الاداء الكبير جدا اللي قدم في
هذه
البطوله بوتر مدرب تشيلسي سيراهن عليه
فيما تبقى من الموسم المتحدث عن نصيري
الذي لم يكن يشارك بشكل كبير جدا مع
اشبيليه
سيعتمد عليه خاصه بضل الظروف غير الجيده
التي يمر بها الفريق في الموسم في الدوري
الاسباني وهو يحتل المرتبه الثامنه عشر
احدى مراتب الهبوط في اسبانيا وقيسي على
تلك الاسماء الكبيره التي تقدم نفسها بشكل
ممتاز جدا في هذه يعني
لها وقتي ولكن سؤال باختصار لالك الى اي
مدى كسر المدرب المغربي وليد الرجراجي
عقده انه لننجح بالبطولات الكبرى يجب ان
يكون المدرب اجنبي
حتى نتذكر جميعا
معظم الانجازات التي حققتها المنتخبات
العربيه كانت بقياده مدربين العرب
نتحدث عن حسن شحاته مع المنتخب المصري
ثلاث ارقام همم همم الثلاثه القاب متتاليه
في بطوله ال- اا امم افريقيا
هي كوره يعني تمكن من ابعادها والسيطره
عليها نعد الحديث اول انجاز الكره
السعوديه كانت تاهل الى اولمبياد بس انجلس
84 بقياده خليل الزياني وكذلك كاس اسيا 84
كان تحت قياده خليل الزياده يعني تحدث عن
التاهل الى كاس العالم 94 لاول مره كانت
بقياده المدرب السعودي محمد الخامس وان
كانت جاء في فتره قصيره لكن هو قائد
المنتخب السعودي يتحدث عن المنتخبات
العربيه الاخرى في كاس العالم 2018 بقياده
نبيل معلول فائده تحدثنا عن المدربين
العرب هم الذين يقدموا الانجازات بشكل
كبير جدا فقط يحتاجون ربما الايمان بقدرات
بشكل اكبر من المسيرين الرياضيين واعطاهم
الفرصه وبالتالي باذن الله عز وجل تتحقق
المغربي يعني
هدف التعادل شكرا جزيلا لك محمد القناص
مقدم الاخبار الرياضيه في قناه العربيه
شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى السياسه قدمت صحيفه كيهان المقربه من
المرشد الايراني مقترحا بغلق مضيق هرمز
الواقعي على الخليج العربي جاء المقترح
بحسب الصحيفه ردا على الدعم الاجنبي
المزعوم للاحتجاجات الايرانيه المستمره
منذ اشهر ضد النظام في طهرانه وشدد رئيس
تحرير صحيفه كيان الذي عينه المرشد علي
ضروره غلق المضيق امام ناقلات نفط الدول
الغربيه والسفن التجاريه ودعت الصحيفه
ايضا في مقالها الف افتتاحيه الى مصادره
الشحنات التجاريه كتعويض عن الضرر المالي
الذي لحق يقابل نظام بسبب العقوبات
الغربيه
الصحفيون والمراسلون قد يكون هذا العامل
اسوا بالنسبه لهذا القطاع اذ سجلت منظمه
مراسلون بلا حدود رقما قياسيا في الحصيله
السنويه للانتهاكات المرتكبه ضد الصحفيين
عبر العالم حيث بلغ عدد المحتجزين
الاعلاميين
50033 اي بزياده قدرها
13.4% مقارنه بالعام الماضي بينما رصدت
المنظمه الحقيقيه مقتل 57 صحفيا على مدى
الاشهر الاثنى عشر الماضيه بزياده وصلت
الى
18.8% يتوسع اكثر من نصف الصحافيين
المسجونين في العالم اعتبارا من الاول من
ديسمبر على خمس دول وايران هي الدوله
الوحيده التي انضمت الى هذه القائمه
القاتمه هذه السنه وابقى اوضحت المنظمه
التي تصدر هذا التعداد السنوي منذ نحو
عقدين ونصف
اكد الامين العام للمنظمه المدافعه عن
حوريه الصحافه كريستوف ديلوار على ضروره
الصمود في وجه الانظمه الديكتاتوريه
والمتسلطه التي تقوم بحشو سجونها بصوره
متسارعه من خلال اعتقال الصحفيين وزجهم في
السجون
اذا ايران احتلت المرتبه الثالثه بحسب
مراسلين بلا حدوده وقد تتصدر القائمه
السوداء بما انها تشهد احتجاجات ستتم فيها
ثلاثه ثلاثه اشهر بعد يومين وكل ما ارتفع
صوت الغاضبين اشتدت يد النظام قمعا خاصه
تلك التي تنقل ما يجري في الشوارع الى
الشاشات والصحف حيث نشرت لجنه متابعه
اوضاع الصحفيين المعتقلين قائمه النهائيه
عن اوضاع 35 صحفيا اعتقلوا وما يزالون رهن
الاحتجاجات وبحسب تقرير اللجنه اعتقلت
ايران منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات وبناء على
تقارير رسميه وغير رسميه نحو 70 نصيحه فيا
تم الافراج عن نصفهم تقريبا بكفاله من
ابرز هذه الاسماء نيلوفر حمدي مراسله
صحيفه شرق الاصلاحيه تم اعتقالها في
الثاني والعشرين من سبتمبر في طهران لانها
نشرت اخبار عن مقتل امين لاول مره كما
اعتقلت قوات النظام الايراني خصر كورد بور
رئيس تحرير موقع موكليان الفارسي الكرديه
واطلقت صراحه واعادت اعتقاله مجددا واخوه
ايضا مسعود كوردبور مدير تحرير مقريان
مازال رحنا الاعتقال اضافه لفاطمه رجبي
الناشطه في مجال حقوق المراه ومن بين
الصحفيين المعتقلين ايضا الها محمدي
في العاصمه طهران والقي القبض عليها بسبب
تقرير لها عن ملابسات مقتل امين بحسب
محاميها
[موسيقى]
منوه الى انه الشوط الاول من مباراه
المغرب وفرنسا انتهى بتقدم هدف مقابل لا
شيء
لفرنسا على حسابي المغرب
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو
في اول تعليق له بعد حكم سجنه قال انه لا
يمكن لاحد ان ياخذ السلطه التي يمنحها
الناخبونه ووصف الحكم الصادر بحقه بغير
القانونيه
بسجن رئيس بلديه اسطنبول المعارض اكرم
امام اوغلو عامين وسبعه اشهر بتهمه اهانه
مسؤوليننا امام اوغلو علق على الحكم
معتبرا انه اختيار واضح للقانون وقال اننا
نشهد تعفنا اداره الدوله
[موسيقى]
حضر الكلام من ان القوات الروسيه تستهدف
منظومه صواريخ باسيوط التي سترسلها واشنطن
الى اوكرانيا فيما اوضح خبراء عسكريون
وامنيون ان العالم لم يشهد اي استهداف
لمنظومه
الصواريخ باتريوت خلال ايام كما وعدتها
واشنطن والكرملين
الى اوكرانيا
تلك الصواريخ رغم محاوله الحلف تجنب
المواجهه مع موسكو لكن ربما
كيف يمكن لروسيا ان تستهدف منظومه
الصواريخ والعالم لم يشهد بعد ان استهداف
لتلك المنظومه
خبراء وعسكريون اكدوا للعربيه ان روسيا لا
يمكنها استهدافه صواريخ باتريوت تحت اي
ظرف خاصه خلال نصب المنظومه الذي يتم بحذر
شديد تحت غطاء جوي كثير يتم تهيئه
المنظومه في مكان بعيد عن اعين الروس ثم
تنقل بعدها الى مسرح العمليات لتفعلها
اوكرانيا ستستخدم صواريخ باتريوت للتصدي
للصواريخ الروسيه بينها اسكندر لان كيف
اصبح لديها اربعه انظمه دفاع جويه حصلت
عليها من فرنسا وبريطانيا و بولندا
بالاضافه الى اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه ما
يعني انك لديها نظام دفاع جوي فريد في
نوعه على مستوى العالم من اوروبا واسيا
وامريكا
كيف ستعمل هذه المنظومه التي تعول عليها
اوكرانيا
تتكون من ثلاثه اقسام هي رادار بامكانه
كشف واعتراض اي مقاتله او طائره بدون طيار
او صاروخ ضمن دائره اشعاعها اكثر من 100
كلم وهذا ما تبحث عنه كيف
المنظومه لها مركز مراقبه يشغله ثلاثه
عسكريين وبطاريه من الصواريخ الاعتراضيه
لصد اي هجمات صواريخ باتريوت ستكون ايضا
عنصرا اساسيا لحمايه الاراضي الاخرانيه
على الجناح الشرقيه ضمن نطاق دفاعات
النيته
ستنشر منظومه باتريوت في مناطق شرقي وجنوب
شرقي اوكرانيا لصد صواريخ روسيا التي
تنطلق من بحر ازوف في الجنوب الشرقي
والبحر الاسود جنوبي اوكرانيا
امريكي
واعطاء البيت الابيض الضوء الاخضر س وشحنه
صواريخ باتريوت الى اوكرانيا وتدريب
عناصرها على استخدامها في قاعده للجيش
الامريكي في المانيا
لبعض المكاتب منذ شهرين ماذا في التفاصيل
7:30
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افاد موقع اكسيوس
الامريكي بان شركه تويتر توقفت عن دفع
ايجار الفواتير الشهريه لبعض مكاتبها منذ
ان استحوذ الملياردار ماسك على الشركه اي
قبل نحو شهرين وبحسب اكسوس فانا موظفي
تويتر وبعض اصحاب العقارات باتم محبطين من
عدم حصولهم على اموالهم وذلك بناء على
رسائل الكترونيه متبادله اطلع عليها
الموقع وافق المصادر فان احد المشكلات
التي تواجهها الشركه الزرقاء لان العديد
من اصحاب العقارات على تويتر اما تم فصلهم
او استقاله تاركين وراءهم موظفين صغار
يحاولون اللحاقه
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم
مشاهدينا الامير الصغير امير كرواتيا كما
يلقب انه اللاعب لوكا مودريتش دينامو
الفريق وصانع العابه حاذف عازف خط الوسط
لمنتخب كرواتيا خلال مونديال 2022 يودع
بطوله كاس العالم بالدموع كما نرى في هذه
الصوره كما غير ايضا من النجوم
التصريح اليوم
في اعلان صادم لمحبيه اكد ليونيل ميسي انه
سيخوض اخر مباراه له في كاس العالم لكره
القدم عندما تواجه الارجنتين الفائز من
مباراه اليوم بين فرنسا او المغرب في
النهائي يوم الاحد المقبل واوضح ميسي
لصحيفه دياريو ديبورتيفو اوليه الارجنتيني
اشعر بسعاده كبيره لانني قادر على تحقيق
ذلك وانهاء رحلتي في كاس العالم
اخر مباراه للنهائي
اما فيديو اليوم فهو من العاصمه يونس
ايريس واحتفال راقصيت سانجو فوق رمادي
نارين بالتاهلهم لنهائي المونديال رقصت
معهم قلوب جماهيرهم جماهيرهم في الارجنتين
حيث احتشد الالاف من المشجعين في الشوارع
وعبروا عن فرحتهم بهذا الفوز الذي قاد
فريقهم الى المباراه النهائيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ملفاتنا لليوم ننتقل الى اخبار الساعه
والزميل عادل يعني عادل نتمنى اليوم ان
يكون اهم خبر عندك فوز المنتخب المغربي
يختلف يمكن يوم امس كانت مباراه كرواتيا
انهار المنتخب الكرواتي في الشوط الاول
لكن الان الى الان فرصه ثانيه امام
المنتخب المغربي العقل مع اخبار الساعه
والقلب متعلق في الشاشات بانتظار التعادل
المغرب وان شاء الله